ce matin les techniciens en
investigation criminelle dépêchés dans
le sud de l'île
ce 7e place des fêtes à ducos procéder
aux formalités d usage ils sont en quête
d'un 10 comme matérialiser devant cette
échoppe
c'est ici que ce jeune fille de 19 ans
qui donne bel ans a été abattu par deux
zones qui lui vole sa moto à la suite de
leurs méfaits
les agresseurs n'ont pas hésité à faire
usage de leurs armes ils tirent à
plusieurs reprises pour s'extirper de
cette place un mode opératoire très
surprenant rien sentiment quand même
d'injustice il y a des jeunes qui
viennent [__] le bordel quoi il ya
ceux qui viennent s'amuser bien ce
qu'ils veulent [__] le bordel c'est
bien dommage tout ça parce qu'il ya 20
ans il y avait un très beau concert qui
se passe est très bien en effet c'est en
marche la manifestation intitulée la
bâche man friday regroupant plusieurs
artistes dont des invités de long 10 de
sainte-lucie que s'est produit le drame
au moment où les organisateurs plier
bagage c'est embêtant pour les bonnets à
son seul bon ce genre d'événement ce
n'est jamais une très bonne publicité
si vous faites le si ce sont des
événements qui est très très lent je
pense que voilà il faut que faut que les
jeunes sachent qu'il faut arrêter il ya
la vie si on vit ils vont bien
respectons-nous un bien triste destin
pour ce jeune homme titulaire d'un bac
en logistique un passionné de moto le
cadet d'une famille de trois enfants
l'autopsié du corps de dylan bellance
aura lieu dans quelques jours l'enquêté
confiée à la section de recherches de la
gendarmerie
les auditions se poursuivent en ce
moment